foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi everybody I'm Josh Welsh president of
film independent welcome to film
independent presents and today's
screening of navalny uh before we get
started with the Q a I just want to
thank our lead funder the hfpa and I
want to thank Vision media our screening
partner thank you so much for making
this year-round program possible and
with that I am enormously happy to
welcome the filmmakers from navalny uh
director Daniel rower and executive
producer Maria pevcheck Daniel and Maria
thank you so much for being here
thank you so much for having us
such a powerful uh And Timely important
film I'm really excited to talk with you
both about it
um
I mean just to kick things off I I have
so many questions about this film Daniel
to start I would love to hear how this
project came to you or or how you
decided to take on this project it's
obviously very different from your last
film once we're brothers the film about
Robbie Robertson and the band
um what is this something you've been in
have you been interested in navalny for
a while or did this come about sort of
fortuitously where how did the project
start well a little bit of both
um and Josh first and foremost thank you
for having us it's delightful to be with
you with you today and we could talk
about the film and thank you all for
watching the film
um you know so often making documentary
films is the art of being the right
place at the right time and I think this
film really exemplifies that I was
working on a completely different story
with with Crystal brosev uh our
Bulgarian nerd of the laptop who was one
of the stars of the navalny film and uh
he and myself and Odessa Ray one of The
film's Producers were actually in
Ukraine working on a completely
different story and that didn't go very
well and we reached a dead end and I was
despondent and trying to figure out what
to do next and that's when Crystal
walked in and uh sort of in whispered
tones uh leaned in and said I think I
might have a lead into who tried to
poison navalny and immediately I sort of
shot up and said who's making that movie
and Crystal was able to reach out to him
on Twitter as we see in the film
um and a week later Odessa Christo and I
were sneaking across Europe essentially
to go and meet with uh navalny and Maria
in The Black Forest to convince them to
make a documentary and and or rather to
convince them to make a documentary with
us and that's how I got involved in the
project and and I'm sure Maria has a
different perspective uh on that whole
time one
foreign
can you say where was navalny in his
recovery process at that he was in the
Black Forest how far along was he in his
recovery at that point when you made
contact I think we've only had had a
Marie you can correct me if I'm off on
the timeline here but I think it was
about seven or eight weeks after navalny
had had woken out from his coma
um and he still looked a bit thin and a
bit gaunt but his his physiotherapy was
was well underway
um in the film we see navalny uh with
one of his personal trainers and he's
working on his hand-eye coordination and
he's juggling I think we shot that
sequence on the second or third day
which would have been November 2020.
um and so I think that gives insight
into where he was at uh he was well
along uh he was well enough along on his
recovery that he was already able to
complete five or six rotations juggling
uh tennis balls which is something I
cannot do uh right even now so he was he
was in pretty good shape but it was
still clear that there was a lingering
uh residual damage uh from this his
attempted murder
so was the first main outside of that
juggling scene where the first main
things that you shot the the interview
in the bar where he's facing directly
the camera actually that interview was
one of the last things we shot we had a
very compressed timeline to shoot this
film we met Alexei and Maria and I think
November 12 13 or 14 2020. so at the end
of 2020
um and we understood at the beginning
that navalny would be going back at some
point in the near future we didn't know
if it would be in 2020 or early 2021 but
it was made clear and we understood that
we had a very compressed timeline with
the subject of this film
um and once we understood when he would
be going back on January 17 2021 uh it
became clear that one of the last things
we had to shoot was this interview and
by that point by the time we shot the
interview I think that there was a great
deal of trust bill but between film team
and the volunteers team or at the very
least between the film team navalny
himself
and he was a very good sport sitting for
That interview it was lengthy and it was
long we shot for I think 13 hours over
the course of two or three days and it's
only in retrospect that I appreciate the
historic nature of that interview it's
the last interview he gave one of his
last acts as a free man and I think that
that just speaks to the significance and
importance of the interview in and of
itself
um so when Maria I'd love to hear from
you on kind of from your perspective the
beginning of the project what was the
idea when this started like what
was it just was it the film that you
ended up with or were you initially
setting out to make something more uh I
don't know more just interviews or what
was the goal at the beginning of the
project that attracted you to it
well we had a very personal goal
um I I came up with the idea that you
know a movie like that would be
interesting while while navalny was
still in coma and I was just we know we
were visiting him every now and then and
you know it's not really fun to visit uh
comatose
um person like you don't really get to
hang out properly and you just you know
you just sit there and wait for God
knows what and obviously I was very um
upset about what happened
um and this um chemical weapons
poisoning you know that's not something
that happens to you every day that's it
um so kind of intuitively I even back in
Siberia when it all happened
um I just started to like film
everything with my phone
um I wasn't sure why and I wasn't sure
what I'm going to do with it and to be
honest and this first you see quite a
lot of that footage um in the beginning
of the film and when we're having
arguments with the hospital staff with
the police there and all of that yeah
um so obviously back then it seems you
know we didn't even know whether navalny
would survive whether he would make it
we didn't know whether he would be
allowed out of Rush or anything like
that so
essentially me and my colleagues just
kind of kept our phones out just in case
um and
um while Alexi was recovering recovering
in Germany I was thinking enough ways of
Revenge and
um and I think that it's this idea of
filming how we are investigating who
boys and famous like it's it's on the
surface
um and um I was absolutely sure that we
would be able to figure out who did it
well to be fair I was absolutely sure
that Putin whether it's his
assassination uh and they they the the
question was just whether we would be
able to arrive and prove to arrive to
the same conclusion you know using some
sort of data in documents and things
like that so we started to investigate
straight away and um as soon as Alexi
was out of coma and he was reasonably
well I just said okay right like that's
that's the film we should we should film
how we are investigating your poisoning
and we'll agree that was a great idea
and it stayed like that that you know
little
amateur video kind of shot in an iPhone
for a while and we have spoken to many
directors who um offered us to kind of
you know do their own version of this
film but it never really we never really
clicked until until that November
meeting with um Crystal Daniel and
Odessa Ray the producer
um when we realized that okay well this
this guy's looks look like the guys who
will be actually able to pick up
whatever we had at this point of time
and continue to film uh professionally
that that's that cell phone footage is
amazing uh I mean first of all it looks
very good for cell phone footage I mean
it looks handheld and everything but
it's the the images are really
compelling but more than that it's the
access I mean the fact that you're there
like that scene in the hospital when the
guards or have the note their masks down
below their noses in the hallway that
whole sequence is amazing and also was
this also cell phone footage when yeah
yeah when navani goes back to Russia
there's footage of him right there at
Customs right when they're finally
arresting him it's kind of incredible
that you have cameras right there at
that moment was that cell phone or
Daniel were you there at that point yeah
that's something I can speak to
um you know that was a unique moment in
in non-fiction filmmaking where we we
understood that something big was
happening there was this big event that
and and uniquely we had the opportunity
to get coverage from you know uh 360
degrees of what was happening
um and so that night for that shoot we
had
four units we had a unit with Christo
and Vienna we had a unit with shooting
Maria and Leonid and I've only Chief of
Staff in Berlin I was on the ground of
Berlin and we had to find two
cinematographers in Berlin with Russian
passports who were brave enough to do
this Mission and go on that flight
because we had no idea what would happen
so we found these two guys who were
Russians living in Berlin who happened
to be cinematographers like the two in
existence and I briefed them for 20
minutes I told them exactly what the
plan was and I I asked the guys how
frightened they were and the first guy
was like I'm the six out of ten and the
other guy was like I'm a you know I'm a
three out of ten and so I said three out
of ten you're sitting in the front and
six out of ten you're sitting in the
back and my directed to them was if
door-to-door gate to gate you're on that
plane for four hours I want you to bring
me three hours and 55 minutes of footage
I want to get every announcement from
the pilot
just shoot everything
well Maria I have a question for you I
mean it's picking up on what Daniel was
just saying but to me one of the most
remarkable things about the film is how
it combines this intimate up close
access to navalny and his family and and
the people in his life
with the scale right this is an
internationally significant historic
Story and there's a sense of the the
great importance of this moment but also
the intimacy of his
you you're with this man seeing up front
what's going playing on his face
hopefully he'll log back in
um was that always the the approach with
this film to kind of combine the the
intimate and the you know
larger story well that's I mean that's
definitely a question to Danielle
because he he he's the filmmaker there
I'm you know in this specific situation
I'm more of a subject really rather than
um rather than the filmmaker so like I
didn't we didn't really
um
plan those things you know like um you
kind of with this film
is you you get what it actually was like
there wasn't my there wasn't any staging
or Preparation or you know decision
making around you know what and where to
film and how and and all of that it's
um well I've been through this through
these days personally I was there and
then I've seen the film as well it's
pretty close to how it actually was like
that that that's that's very
representative and it feels like that
that's exactly how that day for example
the departure date from Berlin to Moscow
that's exactly how it felt like just
loads of you know running up and down
one Corridor like packing things getting
suitcases ready and saying goodbyes and
you know making final plans and
Arrangements
um so um I think that we got to it it
was very generous from navalny and his
family to allow this unprecedented level
of access I was personally surprised
um to um about how you know how patient
they were and uh how much how much time
they agreed to to spend with the film
making team because I mean there is a
huge difference between being filmed on
a phone by your friend uh and being
filmed by a you know a a large film team
with I don't know a sound guy like a
light guy at this guy Etc but they were
very keen and wellness they were very
keen to participate and I think like
this is what made this movie so great
without his sincere desire to make this
movie outstanding I don't think it would
be possible I could never have
anticipated navalny to like spend I
think it was about 15 or 18 hours
actually just sitting still answering
every question
um there is this moment in the film
where I'm asking him whether he when I
think that the camera is open I'm asking
him whether he's comfortable enough
whether he whether he wants this to stop
well like this I don't know silly
questions about his childhood to to go
away and he says and he says no so he
was so open to this idea and um we and
we all were just on on board we decided
uh there was there was not a single
there wasn't another documentary that
was made about this time in in our lives
we weren't giving interviews we weren't
um participating like in in talk shows
or anything like that so whatever
exclusive
um
material that we had we have given it to
this film and I hope that it's paid off
absolutely well welcome back Daniel well
thank you Josh my internet decided to
cut out in the middle of the
conversation so I apologize for that but
I hope that I'm coming too loud and
clear right now and I just want to add a
point to what Maria just spoke to and
that's the question of access and more
specifically navalny as subject and the
genius of navalny as subject this is
sort of a dream come true situation for
a documentarian and we think when I
think of why navalny was so Keen to
participate in this film and give us
this time and attention I think he his
great genius is his Mastery of media and
his Mastery of social media and he
viewed us the filmmaking team and the
entire process as something to weaponize
and I and I mean that in in the most
strategic way for both a politician and
a political dissident I think what
navalny understood was that he was going
to go back to Russia there's a high
probability he would get arrested and he
needed some kind kind of vehicle to keep
his name in the global Consciousness and
I think one of the things that we
offered him was such a vehicle a film
like this of this of the caliber that I
was anticipating and pitching and and
aspiring to create uh would be something
that could Galvanize attention for him
and his plight when he is languishing in
a gulag somewhere
um and it's because of his vision and
his trust and his commitment to that
project and that conceit uh that we are
here now um and he is that's why he is
the most extraordinary subject and I
think that that that just enriches the
film
um holy fully yeah absolutely no it's
it's astonishing I when you cut out I
was saying to Maria the the film one of
the most powerful aspects of the film to
me is how it combines that that in its
access but it's also intimacy of seeing
him like thoughts playing out on his
face the way he interacts with his his
colleagues and his family you're like
right there giving this intimate sense
of the man but it's coupled obviously
with the historical scope of of the
significance of this moment you know
internationally what he signifies and
one thing that I might just add to that
Josh is I remember when we shot that
scene that we were just speaking about
before I cut out
um when Alexei and Yulia were leaving
from in the morning in the hotel room
um and and
it was the most pressure-filled anxiety
and induced learning of my life like
this weight hung in the air it was as if
everybody was like sitting shiva it just
felt heavy and intense and and that was
the first time Alexei actually yelled at
me I I came to his room too early and
and he was so stressed that he just
started screaming and I just sort of
disappeared from the doorway and sat in
a hall and there's a moment in the film
where where we have Alexa apologizing to
me he says Daniel I'm so sorry I just
told you to get the fuck out of here
with your camera
um and that really speaks to like the
intensity of that morning up until that
point he had no problem yelling at his
staff and being like a commanding boss
but the film team occupied a different
space for him uh and the stress of that
morning was just super intense and I
think that moment in the film really
captures what it felt to be there
I I related to that I wanted to talk
about the I don't know the the style of
the film The the genre that you've
created here I mean obviously this is a
very serious documentary but the way
it's edited the pacing uh so many of the
artistic choices this is and it totally
engrossing Thriller right I this feels
like watching All the President's Men or
a political thriller like that where you
like I am leaning in to watch this film
like what is going to happen the stakes
could not be higher but the way you're
telling it I don't it it totally right
this is not a dry detached Talking Heads
documentary this is you are living
through it and the way it's paced and
edited feels like a thriller not in a
way that trivializes the story but makes
it very engaging to viewers and I'm
worried when did you
when did that come about for you as a
filmmaker were you thinking of like in
those terms from the beginning or did
that come when you saw the footage that
you had and how to working with your
editors
I think that we had a sense from the
very beginning that this was a thriller
this was a murder mystery it started off
as a murder mystery more more than a
thriller like a whodunit but we
obviously know who who did it it's just
how did they do it and so we started
following the murder investigation but I
just like
you know I had these points of
references like when I was thinking
about the movie I was thinking about it
in in uh you know in in very cinematic
terms I wanted it to feel exactly as you
are describing it this edge of your seat
Thriller
um and that's how we shot it I wanted to
to shoot it very cinematically with a
soft at the field if a cinematographer
had time to set up a scene
um how would that individual set that
scene up and Nikki waddle who is the
director of photography on this film
those were very much the early
conversations we were having and he did
a very very simple lighting setup in one
of the main spaces where we were
shooting
um and it was just this big Chimera sort
of balloon that he just hung from the
ceiling essentially uh that could just
sit there and it could just it just
covered everything but what it did was
it just made the space bright but also
had this sort of simmering moodiness to
it
um and we just left it there we turned
it on and we left it there and when we
see the phone call scene for example
it it looks like you know a
cinematographer is able to do setups and
light it and bring the camera over here
and get coverage and go click off his
shot list
um but we were just you know very much
doing a verite shooting from the hip
style documentary but we tried to
elevate it
um and you know this question of make it
a thriller uh is is like we wanted to
play with genre in a way the film opens
with navalny directing me here we have
the subject of the film telling the
filmmaker how the film's going to be and
that was really important to us because
a my instinct was to to make it this
propulsive thrilling film
um but I thought it was so interesting
if we added layers to this the onion
that is this movie about sort of like
the meta quality of this social media
genius this politician whose greatest
strength perhaps is Mastery of media
using me as a tool to further his
political goals in a way
um and the entire editorial staff
Langdon Paige and Maya Daisy Hawk were
two of the finest documentary editors on
the planet
um you know they they were the ones I
think who really
shook out that that meta quality of like
who's directing boo here what is it to
make a film about politician
um and how can we bring some of that
fabric into the movie uh and uh I'm I'm
really glad that they had that genius
because it I think it makes the film way
more interesting for viewers yeah
absolutely
um I wanna there's one scene in
particular sequence I want to ask you
about it's it's I keep thinking about it
uh it's the scene
right in the middle of the film where
they are making the phone calls to the
team that they think poisoned him and
the way that they trick those people on
the phone well the first two you know
hang up pretty quickly but the third guy
kind of reveals everything and
navalny is taking such Delight in that I
mean there's this sense of excitement
and also how much he's enjoying the
process I I felt like I got so much of
his obviously I've never met and if on
the outside of this film but I in the in
that moment especially I felt like I got
such insight into who he was as a person
like his strength and incredible
intelligence and of the team in the room
working with him but also how much he
enjoyed it and like he's a consonant
actor right he's he is performing in
that role to trick this guy into giving
all the information and I just I would
love to hear about how you approach that
as filmmakers
um right you presume you didn't know
what was going to happen you were there
to capture it in real time but can you
talk about filming that sequence
well that's precisely right and I think
it speaks to a very important part of
the movie which I spoke to a moment ago
which is this thing of like making a
film about someone who benefits from you
making the film about them and is
somehow weaponizing the filmmaking
process for their own political game and
understanding that navalny is very much
a performer and he loves to perform he
loves to make his YouTube videos and he
loves to look at be on camera and he's
fabulous at it
um I think if he were here he might say
oh I don't love to do that but it's just
part of my job I have to but my read is
that he actually does enjoy it and
Alexei from from what I could tell my
time with him although limited uh was
that he's someone who really enjoys
media and learning about technology and
the internet and and if he weren't in in
prison right now he would be really
interested in learning about
nfts and and Ai and and and he'd be
thinking about how can we take these
utilities and these new types of media
and further are political agenda
um and so when we were shooting that
specific sequence the sequence that it
was praying we see in the scene he
shifts tactics he goes from hi this is
navalny why did you try and poison me of
course that didn't work everybody hung
up
um to taking a more serious approach and
it must be said that navalness
performance playing that role was
astonishingly effective it would be as
if
you call up someone in the American
Military for example and you have to
have the specific jargon and tone to
trick the individual
um Alexei grew up in a military Town his
father was a military man
um and so he had this jargon in this
lexicon that that would make that would
sell it that would make it believable
and from my perspective shooting it we
had been filming for about two hours and
and I had very little expectation that
this whole scheme would work out to
begin with
um and I was sitting back I had my
coverage I was just paying you know
paying attention and and then at one
moment I sort of understood I clocked
even though I don't speak a word of
Russian that
um one of these phone calls was going
longer than the others had been and then
out of the corner of my eye I noticed
that Maria Maria's jaw unhinged and hit
the floor
and that's when I a shot of electricity
ran through my spine and I stiffened up
and I realized that something was
happening here and I just checked the
battery I made sure we had enough space
on our hard drives and I just kept kept
shooting and kept held her steady and
made sure we were in focus and make sure
all systems were go
um and then at one point because I I was
filming and I'm always afraid that if my
Clips if I'm actually filming runs too
long if that file is corrupted you lose
the whole file so every three minutes I
was double tapping which is a risky
maneuver when you're filming but I would
just afraid of of somehow corrupting or
losing the content so we just kept
filming and what that scene feels like
in the movie was what it felt like
shooting it even though I don't speak a
word of Russian and neither did Nikki
waddle uh the Director of Photography of
them
Maria can you talk about your experience
in that scene and did you think when
that started did you have any
expectations of what you were going to
get those guys to say on the phone did
it seem like a crazy scheme or did you
think we're actually going to get them
no we absolutely not like honestly it
was uh among my expectations were below
zero imagine it was like
um it was 4 am I think when we all
gathered in that house to make those
calls the like night before that I was
working
um on an investigation
in parallel we were making an
investigation about Putin's Palace
um so like and it's it's a big big chunk
of work so I was like up until 2 A.M
then had like small nap
um waking up and thinking like oh we
have to to like drive and go and make
those calls and they will be useless
because we make them all the time and
they are useless most of the times to be
fair we will we always try to like
called up whoever we are investigating
and my colleagues who were sharing a
house with me
um I tried to wake them up and say like
oh let's go let's go let's go with me
it's going to be fun and they were just
like no Marie absolutely no way we're
not going we're sleeping uh just wake us
up when you're back and and I remember
that as I needed to drive like for half
an hour or something so I drove picked
up I like saved from you so I was drove
we drove to the to this house where we
shot the phone call and yeah I mean to
be honest I just wanted this to be over
like I wanted to sleep I don't know a
little bit of rest or something and then
the first couple of calls obviously not
all of the calls made it to the film and
first couple of quotes maybe five six
seven were completely useless like
nothing really came out of them
um and
um and then this
happened it was maybe sevens or eights
calling in the row maybe even nines or
something like that and
um when and he um started talking
because first the conversation was
pretty bleak it was like he said that he
had covered and you know it wasn't
really clear whether he is going to say
anything whether he's going to bite you
know
um and uh then I think Alexia asked him
whether he was in Omsk and whether he
travels to and put something like that
and then the guy the FSB guy says he
does like and this is when we all
suddenly woke up you know we're just
like oh he confirmed he was in Omsk you
know that was enough for us that was
enough we would be happily you know we
would happily wrap it up and say look we
confirmed that this guy who we found he
he was on that day you know all adds up
perfect and then he just starts talking
and talking and talking and listening
just describing everything the actual
call the length of the call is I think
like 48 to 49 minutes
uh so you see like two or three minutes
in the film incredible and it's 49
minutes uh we were extremely bored at
the end of this meeting like I remember
Crystal walking out you know to get a
coffee me as well you know because we
were the butcher's bored of the guy like
we asked everything and he he gave us
every tiny detail including like the
color of Nevada's underwear because that
guy was responsible for cleaning
cleaning it's happened for removing
traces of chemical weapons uh from his
clothes and he gave us he confessed that
it was the police that gave him the um
bag with with navalness belongings he
can fast he he gave us every detail of
his trip who he traveled with who asked
him who ordered him who's like
everything he just said everything and
um obviously for us uh it was we
discussed it with with Christos straight
away like after the call finished
um we were just sitting there thinking
this is this is the highlight of our
careers as investigators like nothing
remotely at school can happen to to us
again because like that this is as good
as it gets
um and I don't think that
anything comparable to this ever happens
to it to any other investigator and well
so far it's been two years nothing
um nothing remotely at school has
happened to me sadly but I'm trying not
to lose hope
I do want to quickly mention Josh and
Marie can speak to this
um last week a few of Maria's colleagues
um called up the sun of uh Putin's press
secretary Dimitri peskov and and what
did they do they fooled him again Maria
yeah and I mean that's what we just told
him that we are the
um you know the military people
responsible for for for signing people
up for the Army because there is
mobilization and that's he's being
mobilized and he needs to show up in in
some military and headquarters somewhere
in Moscow and uh yeah the son of Putin's
press secretary started to behave really
finally and he was saying oh do you know
who I am how do you know my surname uh
well I'm not going to there is there
will be an exception for me or something
like that so yeah I mean it does
occasionally work there's prank calls
and sometimes you know like one in the
hundred you can get a decent result and
a fun video out of it but obviously this
call to the poisoner that's that's
that's not the same that's like that's a
live confession yeah to the pur to the
person who you tried to kill I mean like
this is so it doesn't get worse than
that I don't think it gets more
embarrassing but the secret Services
even like theoretically like such a
failure and do you I think this is
alluded to at the end of the film but is
where is that man today
we were pretty sure that he's dead up
until
um maybe a month ago uh because we
managed to locate every other member of
this team
um but not him so you know the other
guys some of them changed names some of
them moved some of them got different
jobs in but we couldn't find any trace
of the guy that we spoke to uh but then
some other database was leaked recently
and it turned out that he was alive in
uh 20 in late 2021 because he took a
covert test and that was leaked amazing
wow so yeah I think it must be still
alive yeah well I I didn't know that
that's I actually I think that's nice
I'm glad he's not dead
well at least uh he wasn't in 2021 who
knows maybe he is now
you're probably sent him to the front
line
Maybe
um I I have one more question or or
subject which is really to talk about
um
the Imp you know I know you had social
impact producers on on the film David
and Nina fialko and I'm I would love to
hear about that like how you approached
the film in terms of social impact but
also related to that I mean I read
like in the last two weeks had an op-ed
in the Washington Post so it's a
two-part question it's like if you could
talk about after the film what what's
your sort of social impact strategy and
then second
I'd love to hear anything about how I'm
like how did navalny get that op-ed out
how is he able to communicate is is
there some open communication where he's
able to get things out or was that all
done surreptitiously
um Maria why don't I answer the first
part of the question then you can speak
to the second uh before we we talk about
the impact producers uh I don't think I
have acknowledged the actual producers
of the film
um Diane Becker Melanie Miller Shane
Boris and Odessa Ray
um and I feel silly for not doing that
off off the top but these are a team of
producers who were extraordinary in
empowering every single aspect of this
production
um uh you know and empowering me fully
uh these this lineup it's like every day
they wake up and they say how can we
Empower Daniel and the and Langdon and
Maya and the filmmaking team and the
creative team and being a young director
and working with producers who were so
empowering was revelatory and
extraordinary
um and and just
a wonderful dream that I'm really
grateful for uh after the film was
finished
um and the world responded really
positively to it impact producers uh
came on board to help us Finance impact
events
um and I think those impact events are
really just to
um uh get the film seen by as many
influential people as possible and as
many everyday people as possible both
like political decision makers the
parliaments embassies
um and uh government governments around
the world who are now responsible for
developing sanctions packages
[Music]
um
um and uh and that's really important I
think for for navalny's security I think
our our thought is that the more people
who know navalny's story The more famous
he is in the global Consciousness is one
of the world's if not the world's
foremost political prisoner the safer he
will be
um in regards to his current situation
and how he's able to communicate with
the outside world I'll let Maria speak
to that
um yeah that's Washington Post
um op ad was was actually it was written
a while ago
maybe a couple of weeks
um and that was when Alexis could
hand write letters and just send them
out
um so there is like no magic to that so
you can do that from prisons I mean
they're being censored but you can still
do that but the situation has changed
since
um they have decided to like harsh
enough the conditions that navalny is is
being kept in quite a lot in the past
four to six weeks and he has been moved
to like a solitary confinement like a
punishment cell where he's on his own
and um it's a tiny little room to buy
three meters um concrete walls and a
little tiny very narrow window close to
the ceiling
um at just a bed a chair and us and a
little table and you're not even allowed
to you cannot even lay down on the beds
during the day or you can really use it
because it's being chained up to to the
wall every morning and it's only being
chained down like at that time so
um that's navalny is live now and now
he's only allowed to use pen and paper
for 35 minutes a day so obviously you
cannot really write a notepad in English
or even in Russian during and that's
that's not enough time so um the sort of
oh Pat why aren't I'm not sure how
whether they will be possible
um from from now up from now on so I
think from around
maybe early September uh probably
coinciding with things going really
badly for for Putin and for Putin's Army
in Ukraine they have decided to silence
him completely as well he was silenced
to a great extent before I mean it's not
like an American prison you cannot like
you couldn't call him or was he wasn't
allowed to he was only allowed to see
his family like once in three months or
something like that he wasn't allowed
any visitors so he was isolated uh to a
huge extent before but now they have
decided to just shut everything down
completely and even in the room where
he's meeting with his lawyers and there
used to be like a glass a plastic glass
between them and they would talk through
this glass and now they have applied
like a non-transparent film to this to
this window so now the lawyers can only
see in the wellness silhouette when when
when they go to cem and hear his voice
so that's that's all we get from him now
is this is probably a very dumb question
but is there any uh campaign in Russia
are there any legal proceedings to get
him out even if they're doomed is it are
there are people attempting within the
legal system to change his sentence or
anything like that it's not possible to
deal within the legal system
his sentence is entirely and completely
illegal it has been reverted by the
European courts of Human Rights we we
have done every step possible and Russia
just ignores the decision of the
European courts of Human Rights so there
is absolutely nothing that can be done
in legal
um in the legal space just because the
for the sentence at the very first place
is completely and entirely made up
and how how many years is his term right
now I think now it's like nine and a
half but he's about to get another
sentence which would be probably around
15 more years oh my God
well there there is that foot at the
very final footage of the film I believe
is of him looking through the bars with
the his shaved head obviously looking
very different was that video captured
back closer to production or is that
more recent footage that was very close
to production that was like within two
weeks from his imprisonment I think now
he looks very different now he uh he
lost a lot of weight he's very very
skinny now uh because they are
um well quite quite quite frankly
speaking they are being underfed they
don't have enough food in prison so if
we're a man who especially for like a
tall man
um who is used to I don't know taking
three meals a day
um this is a bit of a torture because
they literally the portions are tiny and
uh he's just malnutritioned and
um constantly hungry
um this is why he has lost a lot of
weight and he looks he looks now exactly
like he looked after he woke up from
like 20 days of coma wow
well
um
thank you for talking with film
independent I I just again I just want
to say the film is so powerful so well
made and so important and um uh I hope
everybody watches this film if you're by
chance seeing this q a and haven't seen
the film please go watch it
um and uh Daniel and Maria thank you so
much for taking time to talk with us
today
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]